three years on from brexit and leave
voting Towers like Hartley pool are left
wondering was that it but one party is
pushing back
formerly the brexit party now reform UK
they say it's all the conservatives
fault and they have a plan to put it
right this platform of opportunity of
brexit it's still there to be done
we can take advantage and it was
absolutely the right thing to do
Richard Tice came third when he stood
here in 2019 and he believes that he can
win next time but how will voters react
now that the brexit dream he spent years
selling has become reality I've spoken
to people here and up and down the
country who voted for brexit who really
believed in it now they feel that they
were sold a pack of Lies pushed into
making a decision that they regret by
people like you all right well I have to
say I'm astonished you hear that because
I've never heard that and said it to me
yesterday at the bus stop really what
the reality is
um the Tories have just failed to take
advantage of the opportunity this time
round you could take votes from them in
key seats that's the plan the joy of
democracy is that we present a range of
policy options and plans and yeah we
think we've got a better
list of policies that's right for the
country
so how could this plan shape the next
general election
lots of the states that the services won
in 2019 and the
best in the North
places that those that leave it could be
on current polling that reform UK hurts
the conservatives in those seats
can I give you one of those you can
says that we'll decide and we're two
years until the next general election
there's still a long way to go Liz Bates
Sky News Hartlepool